[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and for those who don't know my name is
brani and the series is called they s so
let's see what they have said today so
without further Ado let's dive into
today's episode and remark on a great
journey together get ready to be engaged
entertained and inspired because that's
why this podcast was created in the
first place today's topic will be about
Teen entrepreneurship and I know that
this is one of those very few cases that
you hear these two words come near each
other so already we know te te years the
years that you're supposed to live your
best life
but of course everybody should be able
to choose how he or she chooses to live
those years so we are going to talk
about a few people who have chosen a
different way than the most of
us well there are three people which are
Ashley qual mesiah Bridges and far gray
so let's see what these people are about
so how about we Act actually start from
Ashley
quals well her history is really really
inspiring she's born in 1990 founded
whatever life become at the age of 14
she just has entered her te years just
think about it whatever life.com began
as a website offering free Myspace
layouts and HTML tutorials targeted
primarily at Young girls but through
year through the years she was able to
monetize it and she started earning her
Millions before she even turned
18 so let's continue with maiah brdes he
was born in 2001 and started his bowai
business most bows at the age of nine
okay I chose to talk about Teen
entrepreneurship not kid
entrepreneurship oh my God what am I
doing with my life so mosiah inspired by
his love for dressing up and the lack of
stylish bow ties for children his age he
began making and selling his own bow
ties oh my God please God bless me with
a kid like
him and such a help for him was actually
his grandmother who helped him to start
selling his products and by the time uh
he collaborated with major bands
such as a shark Tang which is like a TV
show for kids I think and uh there he
was solidifying his position as a young
and successful
entrepreneur oh my God and last we
actually have
far oh she uh was born oh my God he's a
he I'm sorry I'm so used to opinion and
once I see a by the end of the I think
she is a she but actually right now it's
a he uh he was born in 1984 in Chicago
and he began his entrepreneurial Journey
at the age of six selling homemade body
lotion and handpainted rocks by the age
of 14 gray had co-founded an investment
fund called the teens scoop corporation
which specialized in making investments
in the stock market and real estate oh
my God he was just 14
his company became a multi-million
dollar Enterprise and by the age of 21
he had become a self-made millionaire
gray is known for his motivational
speaking and has authored several books
including gillionaire nine steps to
becoming rich from the inside out oh my
God so I read many books about uh
business like and authors like Robert
Kaki naon Hill but I have to read this
one too definitely so I think that many
of us are asking how like how did they
do this kind of things well they
probably weren't thinking that we they
are going to become billionaires
overnight that's for sure but I think
they had their own Secrets but you can
ask them for specific on because if
you're in a room of a 100 people
successful people and they you as for
secret you are going to have in your
hand more than 100
secrets so let's
see so here based on my research what is
important is net networking and
collaboration financial management
customer Centric approach effective
planning and
execution vision and
Innovation okay there are a few things
that I think they're right about and of
course they're all needed some more than
other but I think that also patience is
important like why do people expect to
become billionaires overnight I really
don't understand them at that point so
financial management for example is
important all the time if in life but
we're not talking about it we're talking
about how these things actually decided
to go on I think that is really really
important not to think much to think
smart think smart but not hard that's
that's so simple to write to say out but
yes I know it's much much harder to put
it into work but once you do you should
be able to continue like that and not
stop like ever and of course use your
own strategies everybody has its own
strategies and educate yourself in the
field that you decide
to continue on to invest on and I not
talking about education in college or
whatever I'm talking about the education
that you really need maybe you'll find
it in college maybe you will find it in
books and maybe you will find it in
practics
whatever so I think we're coming to an
end and all I can say is that I hope you
have enjoyed this podcast as much as I
had today and thank you so much for
joining us on this episode of the sad
and it's been an incredible journey and
we're so glad that you came along for
the ride so until next time take care we
love you all a lot and don't forget what
we talked about today don't forget the
they s podcast
bye
that